thank you so much it's so important to
me that uh that you could be here
i would never have missed it that's
impossible you know you turned the sound
a couple of times no i'm kidding you did
it
i saw conan and greg daniels come into
snl
1980 they were right out of 1988 it was
just yeah we weren't
out of high school you guys are standing
there like this i was
pretty big on the show at that time you
were a huge star and i'll never forget
you walked into the room
and my writing partner and i were
standing there like this
and uh you came in and um you could not
have been nicer you couldn't have been
nicer to us
i was a good actor in those days huh
i i saw you fresh-faced guys and i
thought well okay they seem all right
and then i went to lauren's office and
what's up he goes
uh i don't think it's going to end well
kenny you guys are awesome and greg
daniels never had an office
isn't that bizarre yeah yeah he created
the office of the american office
come on come on i got nothing
yeah i like a guy who starts his segment
by saying
come on i got nothing
i'm just trying to think is there any
comedian that can go from zero to 300
like you
because you're just like really calm in
the butt right i mean you burst
harder i burst hard yeah yeah i've been
controlled
oh come on this is a show by children
four children knock it off
we're perfect yeah i remember it one
time i was in the makeup chair you're
doing your show and i saw on the monitor
you doing the monologue and all i could
see from the side was what the time was
one of the hardest i've ever laughed i
mean i was like i don't know what you
were
the sound was off it was just a guy
just a lot of desperation a lot of
commitment i always wanted it to be
funny
if the sound wasn't on i i that was
something i used to think about funny
with that
funny with kit like little kids i work
so hard with little kids yeah you go to
a house and there's little kids there
i work real hard and they'll be like two
and they're laughing and i'll say to my
wife
i got him and she's like it's sad
so it's funny with the sandal i sound
off by the way i i don't really get a
chance much i'm sort of launching a new
podcast right now could i just do a
quick thing you can cut it later it's
called kicking it with andy
[Laughter]
how's it kicking i mean it's kicking
great man it's really kicking great
that's great
um i have one with you too
this is kind of how it is now isn't it
yeah yeah you can cut it out it's just i
don't get an audience and stuff this is
just let me just get a shot on myself
here
we're gonna um this is called the best
yet to come with kona no problem
well i'll just anyway i got the
instagram teaser yeah